a breaking piece of news with regard to
Roy more allegations Al Franken fallout
plus CNN does its best to go after Trump
on Russia and falls directly on its face
as does the entire media I'll tell you
about that one plus the mailbag I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show so
the news coming fast and furious today
if my energy level seems a little bit
down is just because I was back from San
Francisco I was there last night doing
sam Harris's podcast was really
entertaining and fun Tim's a really good
guy and while we disagree strenuously on
issues regarding religion we have a lot
of agreement about how arguments are to
be approached and so it was really
entertaining a good time that podcast
should be up I think in the next couple
of weeks is some time so you should
listen for that but I want to get to all
the latest news particularly a piece of
breaking news with regard to Roy Moore's
chief accuser there really - chief
accusers in the Roy Moore case one is a
woman named Lee Kaufman who says when
she was 14 years old that Roy Moore
attempted to molest her and a woman
named Beverly young Nelson who accused
Roy Moore of basically putting on her
car and almost attempting to rape her
when she was 16 years old she's the one
of course who came out with the yearbook
the signed yearbook we'll talk about a
breaking piece of news in that case that
really throws Beverly young Nelson into
credibility crisis I will talk about
that in just a second but first I want
to say thank you to our sponsors over at
quip so let me give you a challenge find
a gift that's affordable practical
instagram-worthy and on top of that list
I will tell you is quip the electric
toothbrush that looks like it was
designed by Apple without the high price
so quip is an electric toothbrush you
can carry it with you on the road
because it doesn't have one of those
expensive and heavy chargers it works
it's very slim package you stick a
battery in it it's ready to go now they
will ship you new brush heads on a
regular basis when you subscribe and it
gives you a really clean mouth I mean I
can tell you that clip works in
fantastically well for me my wife is
also using clip now quip make sure that
the new brush head thing is really
important for me because I'm really lazy
and stupid and in things like this and
that means that I rarely bother to think
about the brush head on an electric
toothbrush unless to actually ship to my
house and then I don't have to think
about it all that's what clip is good
for clip comes with the mount that goes
right on your mirror fits seamlessly
into your daily routine and they have
that optional subscription plan I'm
talking about delivering new brush heads
on a dentist recommended three
months scheduled for just $5 including
free shipping worldwide just in time for
the holidays quip is the ideal size and
price to give anyone on your list the
quip electric toothbrush is featured in
just about every Gift Guide
this year from GQ to Forbes and even
Gwyneth Paltrow's magical goop yes I'm
serious
quip is Best Buy backed by a network of
over 10,000 dental professionals
including dentists hygienists and dental
solutions and starts just 25 bucks and
right now when you go to get quip comm
slash pen that's get quipped calm / pen
you get your first refill pack
absolutely free with a quip electric
toothbrush that's quip get quip calm /
Bend again get Q uip calm / pen and you
get your first refill pack free and the
quip toothbrush starts at just 25
dollars so very affordable a lot cheaper
than it would be if you went to the
store and got a more expensive less good
one so go to get quip comm slash pen and
make sure that your mouth stays clean
okay so the breaking piece of news this
morning is that Beverly young Nelson you
remember her we played significant
portions of her audio when she first
broke news was sitting next to the
execrable Gloria Allred that she was
allegedly molested by Roy Moore the
Senate Republican candidate in Alabama
when she was 16 years old so all the way
back in 1977 she claims that Roy Moore
had met her at a restaurant was hitting
on her wrote her a note in her yearbook
and then one night when she wouldn't
when she'd have a ride home he offered
to give her a ride brought around the
back in the car to lock the door and
then proceeded to try to molest her that
was her claim and she trotted out this
yearbook as proof that she knew Roy
Moore because Moore said he never met
her he'd know who she was
so she trotted out this yearbook and
Moore said it's a forgery and she said
it's not a forgery and actually Gloria
Allred went even further to Gloria
Allred said the entire thing the entire
thing is genuine and the entire thing
was written by Roy Moore well a very bad
thing happened on the way to Beverly
young Nelson's credibility okay and that
is that Beverly young Nelson admitted in
an interview with ABC News that she
wrote part of the inscription now she
didn't write according to heard the
actual note she didn't write Roy Moore's
actual signature but she did write the
date and the place underneath right now
the reason that this is a problem I'll
show you I'll show you what she had to
say the reason this is a problem is
because if they just come out at the
very beginning and they'd said Roy Moore
wrote this note and then to remind
myself where this was I wrote the
eight and the place underneath right
just like you would on the back of a
photo everybody would have gone okay
especially because there's now a second
note that Roy Moore wrote a graduation
card to a seventeen-year-old
that looks very much like this no right
the signatures look pretty much the same
but because people were automatically
saying this was a forgery and because
Gloria Allred refused to turn it over to
any sort of impartial third hand source
or secondhand source or refused to turn
over to any sort of handwriting expert
because of all that this now throws the
entire story in jeopardy
here's Beverly young Nelson talking
about this and admitting that she wrote
the little inscription under the note
Young's proof that she knew more her
yearbook with this inscription but Moore
and his supporters have called into
question that inscription noting the
riding under the signature appears to be
different let's look at Beverly Nelson
everybody knows her in yearbook is a
forgery Nelson says she did make notes
to the inscription but the message was
all Rome or Beverly he signed your
yearbook he did sign it and you made
some notes underneath yes okay so how
number one does the GMA reporter who's
reporting that's not ask why when were
the notes made what were the specific
notes made right it says the date and
the and the and the the place the this
steakhouse that apparently she worked
now does this throw the entire story
into into severe a credibility crisis
not quite because Roy Moore said he
never knew the woman he said that the
restaurant didn't exist the signatures
again looked the same they should submit
it now to an independent handwriting
expert they should have already Gloria
Allred is a hack it's unbelievable to me
that Gloria Allred's didn't submit this
in the first place but there is a
tendency to run too far with the story
so I'm seeing headlines today as a
headline from Breitbart bombshell she
admits she forged the signature no she
did not admit she forward us the
signature what you just saw is the
entirety of the tape right the actual
headline over at Breitbart right now I
want to make sure that I don't I don't
give a steer you bomb on what exactly
their headline is bombshell more accuser
admits forging yearbook silence for
weeks as evidence of hoax grew write
more admits admits forging yearbook she
did not admit forging the yearbook she
admitted to writing a note underneath
the signature so again this throws no
credit to things can be true at once won
her credibility can be it can have
serious problems now because she didn't
admit the
from the start and because gloria allred
openly stated the entire thing was
written by this woman but it's also true
that she didn't admit to forging the
entire note she specifically said she
didn't Forge the entire note in this
particular element so I don't know why
people have to lie about what yeah I
really don't know why people have to lie
about what exactly she admitted in order
to throw this woman's credibility into
crisis I don't really understand how how
that's the case it's it's confusing to
me but again it does have a real
credibility problem and there gonna be a
lot of people who hang their hats on
this peg now again she's not the only
accuser against forum or there's another
accuser who says she was molested when
she was 14 that was the one that was
tracked down by the Washington Post
they're a bunch of other women who say
that Roy Moore was dating them and
trying to kiss them and hit on them when
they were under the age of 18 there were
many of those women there were reports
that he was banned from the local food
court at the mall but all of that said
is this a problem for beverly young
nelson it is but it shows the dishonesty
of our politics number one that gloria
allred didn't admit this stuff up front
and number two that GMA didn't bother to
press the questions and number three the
people are now saying this discredit the
entirety of the signature and the note
because it doesn't okay so all of those
things can be true once it can also be
true that this doesn't really change
some of the underlying other allegations
that people are using this to to dismiss
all the allegations all the other
allegations are now dismissed because
there is this this problem with Beverly
young Nelson's credibility now that
seems to me
overkill as well so with all that I'm
trying to give you the most
intellectually honest take I can it's a
serious problem for her credibility it's
a serious problem for Gloria Allred who
once again demonstrates to the world
that she is terrible at her job and as a
hack lawyer and Ana troll but it doesn't
do it doesn't do it doesn't carry all
the heavy weight that I think a lot of
people wanted to carry the weight that
says that Roy Moore is now off the hook
I think that's that's a little bit
that's a little bit of a stretch all all
that being said Roy Moore is gonna win
there's no question the Roy Moore is
gonna win this election now he's gonna
win the election by eight to ten points
he was already winning the election
these charges that started to fade in
the public memory and not only in the
public memory but in the minds of a lot
of conservatives because conservatives
have made the concerted effort now the
concerted move that they have decided
that when so on the initial attack on
somebody like Roy Moore is initially
over an issue where they agree with Roy
Moore
then all further attacks will be
attributed to malice add motivations and
fraud right it's not just with Roy more
this is true for Donald Trump too when
the initial attacks on Donald Trump were
suggestions that his right-wing views
made him unpalatable then when there
were later suggestions that were of a
more personal nature everybody just
rocked that up to media animus for
Donald Trump the same thing is true of
Joe Arpaio Joe Arpaio in Arizona is now
apparently considering a run for the
Senate he told the daily what are the
daily beast that he is seriously
seriously seriously considering running
for the US Senate to repeal to replace
Jeff Flake he'd obviously have an upper
hand in the primaries because
specifically because of all the media
attacks on him because he had to be
pardoned by President Trump and that
means that a lot of people on the right
think that he's a martyr to the cause
right that he's somebody who is anti
illegal immigration he is somebody who
used to dress up his prisoners in pink
outfits we like that sort of stuff since
we don't like crime and we don't like
illegal immigration and the initial
media attacks were on that stuff not on
corruption in the Maricopa County
Sheriff's Office which apparently did
exist they paid a 3.5 million dollar
settlement to a local newspaper after
trying to arrest newspaper reporters for
reporting on a subpoena but all of that
puts it aside one of the things that
unites the sort of feeling for Trump and
Roy Moore and and ang RPO is this
feeling like if the initial attack on
them was over their conservatism or over
their right-wing views then all further
attacks must be discredited based on the
malice of the media and the media
doesn't help its own case when it
doesn't press Beverly young Nelson for a
better explanation of why they didn't
come out with this fact earlier why it
was weeks before they came out with the
fact that the last two lines of this
thing at the very least according to
Beverly young Nelson were written by
Beverly young Nelson so yeah I think
that Republicans are being a little
disingenuous if they say that all
allegations against Joe Arpaio are false
because the initial attack on Joe Arpaio
was wrong or all the allegations against
Roy Moore are false because the initial
attack on Roy Moore was wrong over the
10 commandments stuff like the fact is
that Roy Moore says a lot of stuff that
is inappropriate he says a lot of stuff
that is bad but because again I think
that you basically have ten seconds in
the public eye to make people's minds up
about what exactly you are then once
their minds been made up it's almost
impossible to change them
is actually what the social science data
tends to suggest then when you walk down
the street you make a decision within
the first 10 seconds of meeting someone
whether you like them or not and it's
very difficult to change your opinion
the same is true in politics the first
impression is the lasting impression
that people have about you with regard
to politics the first impression about
Roy Moore is that he was a very
religious guy who took the Ten
Commandment seriously and wasn't going
to bow to judicial supremacy and that
image has basically carried him through
all of the credibility questions about
him it carries him through with saying
ridiculous things right in just a second
I'm gonna play you a quote by Roy Moore
himself that if any Democrats had at the
right would be going nuts but the right
doesn't care because anything that is
used to attack worry more is now being
seen as bad faith here is a little bit
of the the tape that I'm talking about
Roy Moore was asked by the Guardian
about Ronald Reagan once saying that the
Russians were the the evil empire and
the focus of evil in the modern world
and here was Roy Moore's answer he said
the Russia was the focus of evil in the
modern world you could say that very
well by America couldn't you do you
think well we promote a lot of bad
things you know like same-sex marriage
that's the very argument of aladdhin
mere Peter makes well then maybe Putin
is right maybe he's more kin to me than
I know okay so if any Democrat said that
right that America's the focus of modern
evil in this world and then they cited
say not same-sex marriage but but high
tea but low taxes and then they said
maybe Putin is right we'd lose our minds
but Roy Moore says that is totally fine
again because people have made up their
mind about Roy Moore already the same is
true there's a quote apparently and I
don't want to put too much stake in this
quote I'll read it to you and then I'll
tell you why according to the LA Times
Roy Moore in September was asked about
when he last thought America was great
because he's run very much on they make
America great again kind of bandwagon
and more apparently acknowledged the
nation's ugly history of race and racism
and then he said I think it was great at
the time when families were united even
though we had slavery they cared for one
another our families were strong our
country had a direction so the way the
media has run with this is saying that
Roy Moore says the last time America was
great as when there was slavery I don't
think that's what Roy Moore is saying
but it's certainly badly our
it's another one of these cases where
because we just trust the media on the
right we want the entire context we
don't trust them to tell the truth and
this is just another example of why that
is so that distrust of the media allows
people to take a molehill and make it
into a mountain in the case of Beverly
young Nelson and all the rest of the
accusers it allows them the ability to
hang their hat on pegs that are not
particularly sturdy again does this call
beverly young Nelson herself in a
question absolutely does it call Gloria
Allred in the question absolutely and I
will only follow where the evidence
leads when she first came out I said I
thought this was very credible I think
it's a lot less credible now that that
you have this this statement that she
wrote in the yearbook herself do I think
it completely destroys her credibility
no I'm not willing to go that far but
it's a problem for her that said for
people to say this destroys all of the
allegations against Roy Moore is is an
overkill that I think is pretty
shameless okay before I go any further
and I'll talk a little bit about Al
Franken first I want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at us ECA so right now
do you remember that gun giveaway I told
you about a little bit earlier this week
well if you want and you really do have
to hurry the US ECA wants to give you
for free chances to win a brand-new gun
plus all the ammo you will need to break
it in entry is simple easy and free but
it's almost over go to defend my family
now one calm is defend my family now the
number one dot-com to lock in your entry
this is your last chance to register if
you win you'll get $1,000 for a brand
new gun in the ammo of your choice
remember it's not just one gun you get
four chances to win not only is the US
ECA on a mission to make sure every
responsible gun owner is educated
trained and insured they like giving
away guns to law-abiding people because
while biting people with guns are able
to defend themselves in their country
you're running out of time
don't miss your last shot at getting
that gun you really want for Christmas
hurry over to defend my family now one
comc which gun is waiting for you defend
my family now 1.com so if you were
waiting for the Red Ryder BB gun but now
you've upgraded to an actual AR then
defend my family now one calm is the
place to go go ahead and check that out
okay so while the Republicans are having
all of this hubbub over more mother more
is guilty or innocence and Joe Arpaio
and Trent Franks so Trent Franks stepped
down yesterday he says he's gonna step
down from Congress because two former
female staffers are now complaining of
sexual harassment apparently franks said
that he and his wife have been
struggling to get pregnant and that he
discussed surrogacy with two women in
the workplace and it caused them to
stress I'm confused as to why that
exactly would be sexual harassment
unless he said I want to put a baby in
you in which case it is sexual
harassment
but if it was you work here I trust you
seem like a nice gal have you ever
considered surrogacy I'm not sure why
that sexual harassment per se like I
just may be the power melons but that
doesn't seem like typical sexual
harassment to me so I'm not sure we're
getting the entire story on that well
all that breaks down on the Republican
side the Democrats are preening the
Democrats are walking around preening we
are just the moral guideposts for the
United States we are the most moral of
the moral this is the new shtick that
Democrats have been trying out on a
regular basis yesterday Al Franken did a
bad job with it right he he tried to
grab the moral high ground but that
failed because Al Franken wasn't really
willing to acknowledge that he'd done
anything wrong here's what Al Franken
said yesterday and in saying that he was
going to resign now that he did resign
yesterday but he would resign in short
order if more gets elected and is not
thrown out of the Senate I think there's
a significant possibility that Franken
actually retracts his retirement and
says you know what I'm gonna stick
around now if the Republicans aren't
gonna clean house I'm certainly not
gonna leave over this here's what Moore
said yesterday Franken said yesterday
nevertheless today I am announcing that
in the coming weeks I will be resigning
as a member of the United States Senate
I of all people and aware that there is
some irony in the fact that I am leaving
while a man who is bragged on tape about
his history of sexual assault sits in
the Oval Office and a man who has
repeatedly preyed on young girls
campaigns for the Senate with with the
full support of his party ok so there he
there he does is he also called himself
a champion for women and said that the
women who are accusing him and gotten it
all wrong but he's stepping down anyway
it's hard for you to claim the moral
high ground when you're blaming the
women right I thought the whole shtick
here is that women always have to be
believed
unless you're Al Franken and Franken
himself he you know he is his accusers
are angry at him and I think for good
reason one of the Franken accusers she
comes out and she says she's just
appalled that Franken won't up to
own up to the situation and so is there
anything that for you would be justice I
I have to say that I I'm so sad and
appalled at his lack of response and him
owning up to what he did I feel that he
just keeps he just keeps passing the
buck and making it out to be something
that we we took his behavior the wrong
way or we misconstrued something it's
hard for them to grab the moral high
ground in any case while they're busy
giving it away but they're trying to
grab the moral high ground anyway right
they're trying to say that Republicans
don't understand the plight of women but
we Democrats we understand the plight of
women now this is all cynical pandering
I mean what they're actually attempting
to do is flip the script so they can go
after more and Trump right that's the
whole goal here is that okay we'll
sacrifice one of ours and then we'll use
their bodies as a bridge in order to in
order to climb the ramparts of Trump and
and Roy Moore that's the whole goal here
and you see Chris Matthews did the
clearest and dumbest version of this so
last night on his show he got up younger
they show good I might say he talked
about Democrats a great people the
entire world is just that does fantastic
go chasing your thoughts about the
possibly positive education that the
public hearing I don't know how you can
avoid the education in this the worst
you can say about the Democrats is
they're too pure and that's the good
thing to say but that's the worst thing
you can say about these guys said to
highest standard for public office
yeah that's clearly the worst thing you
can say about Democrats and their to
appear the only pets the only you can
say I mean preening just
self-aggrandizing stupidity of this
nonsense that the only thing Monica
Lewinsky's dress disagrees all right the
Ted Kennedy's sexual assault victims
disagree the worst you can say about
Democrats that they're too pure but this
is their new routine we have the moral
high ground and you can see how cynical
this is right Democratic Representative
Katherine Kathleen Rice she comes out
and she says you know really the guy who
should resign here is of course Trump
Trump is the one who should really go
now
although Democrats you know
our leadership came to this issue a
little late they did call on the
resignations that have happened and we
need the Republicans to do the same
thing we need Paul Ryan to stand up and
be the leader of his party I know it's
difficult for him to do that when the
standard-bearer of the Republican Party
for right now is the President of the
United States and we know his history
with this issue of harassment so my hope
and my call is for Paul Ryan and the
Republican leadership to get with the
program and start forcing people out why
shouldn't he resign today like Franken
did if you're being consistent said
before that he I have said before that
he should I don't think that's gonna
happen
right that's the cynical move the
Democrats are making but they're
claiming that they have the moral high
ground while they're doing it again two
things can be true that Franken probably
should go and also the Democrats are
using this for cynical reasons but the
preening is a little much or I mean that
the Democrats for claiming themselves on
loan from God is pretty astonishing
Nancy Pelosi did that as well yesterday
she extended it right not only are they
Nancy Pelosi was defending Al Franken
until five seconds ago and John Conyers
until five seconds ago
not only does it turn out that the
Democrats have a direct pipeline to God
when it comes to sexual harassment they
also have a direct pipeline to God when
it comes to legitimizing the children of
illegal immigrants who came here when
they were kids we're not going to turn
this country into a reign of terror of
domestic enforcement look at the jet and
have the daca the dreamers pay that
price but the I'm optimistic I always
have been God is with us on this our
country is great we know their greatness
Springs from the vitality that newcomers
bring to our God is with us you
understand
they're so holy now don't you see the
holiness that they have in getting rid
of Al Franken has now translated over to
everything including daca and the
killing of human babies in the woman
till the ninth month it's just amazing
how this has happened so before
everybody jumps on their high horse and
talks about how the Democrats have their
holy and now they're they're all
wonderful and they're too pure as Chris
Matthews says yeah not so much okay so I
want to talk a little bit about media
malfeasance this is an amazing story so
CNN reported this apparent bombshell and
they got it totally wrong I'll explain
all of it to you in just a second but
first I don't
say thank you to our sponsor over at men
crates so this is one of my favorite
sponsors man crates calm it is the best
gift that you can get for any man in
your family is it great for dads it's
great for sons it's great for husbands
it's great for any man in your family
who is who really is into anything from
whiskey appreciation to grill master to
sports stuff here's what it is a special
basically gift package that comes in
either an ammo crate or in an actual
wooden crate with an engraved with an
engraved pride pride thing with engraved
crowbar come out of it today
with an engraved crowbar and you can
actually pry open the crate yourself
it's it's super in a it's super
ennobling it makes you feel like a man
it feels like you're king our Thor
pulling the sword out of the stone but
instead you're actually pulling a crate
of whiskey out which is pretty amazing
they cover over 100 hand curated gift
collections for every type of guy from
the rugged outdoorsman to the sports
fanatic everything in between as I said
last time I got an entire set of poker
chips from man crates I immediately gave
them to one of my friends will actually
use it because I think I'll only end up
playing poker at his house but it is it
makes a fantastic gift and it's just
it's hilarious it's fun it's something
that your loved one will get a kick out
of it's great for Christmas or Hanukkah
or any other special event they have
thousands of five-star reviews every man
crate comes with a high-five guarantee
on the holidays go man crates calm slash
bending at 5% off your order
5% off your winning go to man crates
calm slash Ben that's man crates calm /
Ben five percent off your order and
again I get such a kick out of these but
I really do get a kick out of these
gifts they're really fun go over to man
crates calm right now check it out it'll
solve all of your gift-giving needs okay
so here is the story from CNN and this
just shows you you want to know why so
many people are skeptical of the media
even on things like Roy Moore you cannot
count out the fact that the media are
willing to jump over any barrier in
order to get Republicans they really are
and so when you ask when the left looks
at us and they say on the right how
could you possibly how could you
possibly not just credit the media with
great reporting when they report
something it's because within three
hours half of this stuff gets
discredited half is a little much but a
certain percentage of
gets discredit so for example there was
a report from CNN and the report from
CNN said that on September 4th there was
an email that was sent to the Trump
administration - Donald J Trump -
channel 2 Donald Trump jr. - other
members of the administration and that
this email had a key code a decryption
key for WikiLeaks that had not yet been
released publicly as a big scandal if it
turns out then that's one step removed
from actual collusion right if it turns
out that the WikiLeaks people at the
behest of the Russian government send a
decryption key the Trump administration
the Trump campaign and that the Trump
campaign used it in order to go in and
spy on Hillary Clinton's emails before
those things were released publicly that
would look a lot like collusion would it
not it turns out every elements of the
stories bullcrap every single one so
first of all the email was not sent on
September 4th before the wiki leaks were
leaked it was sent on September 14th
after they were all are in public
information you didn't need a decryption
key for public information number two
there's no evidence that Donald Trump
jr. or Donald Trump ever saw this email
number three there's no evidence that
the email itself is legit that it didn't
just come from some spammer so the way
that this originally was run the way the
original headline was run was something
like I want to I want to find if I can
the actual headline CNN report Trump and
Trump jr. got September 2016 email with
decryption key
right here's what David Wright from CNN
tweeted he tweeted candidate Donald
Trump Donald Trump jr. and others in the
Trump org received email in September
2016 offering a decryption key and
website address for hacked WikiLeaks
documents according to email provided to
congressional investigators write
bombshell before any of this was public
they were being offered a special in by
WikiLeaks aka the Russian government
except again it turns out it may not
have come from the Russian government
there's no evidence Trump looked at it
and the email came ten days after the
initial CNN report said which means that
the email came out after all the
information was public I mean this is a
Brian Ross level screw-up it is a
massive massive screw-up somebody needs
to get suspended for it at the very
least because to misreport in that from
Attica fashion does a disservice to the
Trump administration then you wonder why
Trump runs around shouting fake news you
wonder why Republicans distrust
reporting from places like the
Washington Post
you wonder why Republicans have now come
to the
conclusion then nothing can be trusted
part of it is because they're taking the
message too far but part of it is
because there is a grain of truth which
is that a lot of the media are willing
to jump on stories that have not been
vetted and are not true in order to
promulgate a particular narrative and
this is just the best example of that
Democrats are doing this too
representative hooli and Castro who has
presidential aspirations he comes out
and he says that don't worry even though
there really is no hard information
connecting trump and russia at this
point disturbing things will definitely
come out I mean come on well as you know
I can't discuss most of that stuff now
but you know I told you months ago and
when I said it back then I think it was
considered a little bit brash but I said
I think in April that I thought that
there would be people who would end up
in jail and and as I stand here now I
think that there gonna be some things
that come out that will be very
surprising and disturbing right they
just want to read the chyron right this
is earlier this was earlier yesterday
and says CNN exclusive undisclosed email
show follow-up after Don jr. meeting
with Russians at Trump Tower but the
follow-up didn't actually have anything
bad to that either there's no evidence
that any follow-up was even responded to
by the Trump people
so everything that CNN is reporting and
when you watch CNN half their coverage
is about Russia stuff there not only is
there no smoking gun there is no bullet
there's no gun like we I don't even know
what these stories are supposed to be
proving when they're this bad and then
they and then again it's amazing to me
people are wondering how could it
possibly be how can it possibly be that
people don't trust the mainstream media
this is why people don't trust the
mainstream media seriously okay I mean
wow there's more fallout over the
Jerusalem situation so Donald Trump I
have to give him credit for this tweet
this tweet he gets credit for it he
moved the he says he's gonna move the
embassy to Jerusalem acknowledges
Jerusalem is the capital of Israel as
I've said initiate a move of moral
bravery and courage and he released this
tweet which is I have to say pretty
funny he tweeted out above this I
fulfilled my campaign promise others
didn't full credit to trump this is
exactly true now there's a lot of
violence that has been breaking out
around the world there are clashes in in
Judea Samaria and the Gaza Strip Hamas
of course calling for an uprising
because they're a terrorist group that's
what they do one Palestinian protesters
been shot dead but to be frank with you
the levels of terror
that I've seen so far the levels of
violence that I've seen so far have been
relatively innocuous so they say that
their rallies in Malaysia Indonesia Iran
Syria and even America ooh I mean people
in Syria are angry oh noes
you mean people in Iran are upset well I
guess that changes everything because
Iran was our best friend before you mean
Muslims in Malaysia are very upset about
things well unless people are actually
like getting hurt or killed I don't
really see so what their protest big big
freaking deal they protest over if you
if you said tomorrow we're gonna have a
Day of Rage well we'll call it the Nakba
right the day that Israel was
established the Palestinians called the
knock by the disaster will have a day of
rage on that day you don't the same
people protesting there's nothing to it
Jerusalem it has to do it the fact they
hate Israel it's that simple so Thursday
apparently there were 16 Palestinians
wounded they said that most of the
injuries were from tear gas and rubber
bullets and and of course you have all
of the all the usual leftist suspects
saying this is going to be the end of
the world it won't be the end of the
world Trump was right to do it
I do want to point out how the media
have exacerbated the situation so
Richard angle the media like to embed in
the Middle East in in places like Gaza
and then they just stand around with
cameras and watch people burn their own
towns and then they treat it as though
something heroic is taking place this is
in Ramallah Ramallah is completely run
by the Palestinian Authority the
Israelis do not run Ramallah and Richard
Engel over on NBC here as here's him
reporting good morning as you can
probably see clashes and civil unrest
have broken out here in the West Bank we
are on the outskirts of the Palestinian
city of Ramallah these protesters have
begun setting fires they're burning
tires to create a smoke screen and they
are throwing stones and other debris
it's difficult to see but behind this
smoke our Israeli troops and they have
been firing volleys of tear gas
occasionally to drive the demonstrators
back all these protesters say they are
here for one reason because Palestinians
they say will not give up on their right
to Jerusalem no matter what President
Trump says okay well the me look at the
excitement from Richard Engel you can
see the media are really turned on about
all of this what would happen let me
just pose something what would happen if
the media minimized the coverage in the
same way that the media minimize the
coverage of serial killers but this
seems to me very much like the coverage
of the riots in Ferguson or the riots in
Baltimore the media love the stuff
and they egg it on and then they're
surprised when violence breaks out that
doesn't wash it doesn't wash at all okay
so in other news now there are a couple
of stories that are kind of astonishing
today so one is with regard to yours
truly so apparently I was supposed to
speak at Concordia College Concordia
College in Moorhead at things in New
Hampshire and they had funded it the
Student Government Association had voted
to fund it in November 30th they voted
13 to 10 to allocate about $7,000 to
young America's for freedom to fund one
of my appearances and now student
leaders voted 28 to 2 against funding it
so they would through the funding more
than 150 students and faculty filled
Barre auditorium for an hour-long
discussion leading up to the vote that
nullified a previous decision to have me
and the SGA sent an executive email said
SGA's first goal is to listen to
represent and act on the feedback of its
students and there will be a motion put
forward to rescind the funding you're
welcome to add to the discussion during
the meeting some concordia students
according to the motion to rescind
funding have a sort of that Shapiro's
harmful messages targeting LGBTQ qya
Elzey communities and other marginalized
identities is in direct opposition to
the dedication of Concordia and SGA to
support diversity equity and inclusion
of all persons from all backgrounds and
identities so this was an appeasement
move it's pretty astonishing and and
pretty obvious young Americans for
freedom at Concordia they said bringing
ben shapiro to campus would be assigned
from Concordia College that they value
intellectual and political diversity and
that they care about the marginalized
and underrepresented conserved
underrepresented conservative voices on
campus but they're not gonna do it
they've decided that it's not about
diversity instead it's mostly about
shutting down people who you don't like
it's shutting down folks that you don't
like which of course we already knew
from my experiences on college campuses
before speaking of free speech concerns
isn't a formal free speech concern
because I believe Concordia is a private
college they can do whatever they want
it does demonstrate that they're
supposed to commitment to free speech
however is a joke but you know in terms
of social Center for unpopular opinions
that are true this is an astonishingly
bad story so there's a woman who's a
porn star or was a porn star her name
was August Ames and she's 23 she was
found dead from an apparent suicide
she was bullied and branded a homophobe
for refusing to shoot with a man who has
sex with men on camera she made it clear
she was not homophobic apparently she's
bisexual or was bisexual but she said
that she wasn't gonna do it for safety
reasons so law enforcement sources said
that Ames was found early Tuesday
morning in Camarillo she was pronounced
dead at the scene we're told there's no
indication of foul play or any other
crime occurring toxicology tests are
being conducted while the death is
investigated close friends say she'd
suffer from long-term depression and
they believe a recent incident with
online harassment may have contributed
to her death the backlash was fierce
when she took to Twitter on Sunday to
warn women who had been tapped to
replace her at erotica acts that the man
she'd be worked that she'd be working
with has filmed with other men so
whichever lady performers replacing me
tomorrow for erotica X news you're
shooting with a guy who has shot gay
porn just to let you know BS is all I
can say do agents really not care about
who they're representing I do my
homework for my body she was ridiculed
as homophobic she wrote not homophobic
most girls don't shoot with guys who
shot gay porn for safety that's just how
it is with me I'm not putting my body at
risk I don't know what they do in their
private lives she says how am i
homophobic if I myself am attracted to
women not wanting to have sex with gay
men is not homophobic they don't want to
have sex with me either so by okay that
seems to me completely fair but the
point that she's making here is a
statistically true one okay the rates of
STDs in among men who have sex with men
are significantly higher than they are
among men who have sex with women right
STDs among men who have sex with men are
much much higher they just are and the
idea that a homosexual man or a man who
has had sex with men was is is going to
sex the woman it increases her risk it
increases her ass pretty dramatically
actually I'm looking up some of the
statistics if I can find them from from
some of the more recent CDC statistics
so let's say less able to find something
really quick here so gay bisexual and
other men who have had to this front
corn CDC gay bisexual other men who have
had sex with men are 17 times more
likely to get anal cancer than
heterosexual men gay and bisexual men
are significantly more likely to have
other forms of STDs CDC recommends
sexually active gay and bisexual men
test for HIV at least once a year
hepatitis C hepatitis B gonorrhea
medea right the rates are jet that
they're higher because they're higher I
mean there's there's nothing else to say
about that and so the idea that this
woman was basically run off Twitter and
then she committed suicide over this it
demonstrates the insanity of the social
censoring that goes on on social media
like Twitter people digging up tweets
that are ten years old or finding a
tweet these said yesterday that's
completely innocuous and then taking it
out of context in order to hurt you it's
it's over it's it's just overboard it's
all overboard and people need to rein it
in there's a digital lynch mob that
exists now and it's pretty scary out
there okay so I do want to get two
things I like things I hate and the mail
bag will do a nice mail bag today but
for that you're gonna have to go over to
Daley wire.com and subscribe for $9.99 a
month you can get a subscription to
Daley wire.com you get the rest of my
show live on video you get the rest of
Clavin show live on video Knowles's show
live in the video on video be part of
the mailbag today and next Tuesday we
are having an episode of the
conversation which means that you get to
ask me your questions but only if you
are a subscriber everyone gets to watch
on facebook youtube but only if you're a
subscriber do you actually get to ask
questions yourself and have them answer
to make your life better that's December
12th at 2 p.m. Pacific 5:00 p.m. Eastern
will stream it live on the Ben Shapiro
Facebook page The Daily wire YouTube
channel again free for everybody to
watch but only subscribers can ask the
questions you get all of that when you
subscribe plus if you get the annual
subscription you also get this the very
greatest in all beverage vessels leftist
Cheers hot or cold tumblr it does indeed
hold both hot and cold tears as well as
other beverages that may be more
sanitary check it out over at our
website daily wired icon subscribe 9 9
dollars a year so a lot cheaper than the
monthly subscription or if you just want
to listen to the rest of the show later
go over to iTunes SoundCloud make sure
that you subscribe and hit download over
there YouTube please subscribe over
there we have some funny new videos
coming out you'll want to be a part of
we are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
all righty so let's do a quick thing I
like in a quick thing that I hate and
then we will move to the mailbag so
things I like today I should have a
couple of things that I like today so
watching all this hubbub over
particularly crappy candidates on both
sides of the aisle makes it reminds me
of movie called the best man this is not
a well remembered movie that's Henry
Fonda and Cliff Robertson Edie Adams
very good cast the movie was written by
gore Vidal so it is a left-leaning
movie but the basic plot of it is that
Henry Fonda is a former Secretary of
State based on Adlai Stevenson who's
supposed to be running for president and
Cliff Robertson is supposed to be based
on Richard Nixon he's running for
president - cliff Robertson's the bad
guy Henry Fonda's the good guy and
basically they are the two leading
candidates for president battling it out
the question is who's gonna win and what
sort of dirty tricks they'll use it an
open convention in order to win it's
entertaining it's definitely
entertaining and it doesn't say
something about about you know what what
lengths people are willing to go to for
power this is Secretary of State William
Russell candidate for president of the
United States is he the best man you
have no sense of responsibility toward
anybody or anything and that is a
tragedy and a man and it is a disaster
and a president this is Senator Joe
Cantwell candidate for president of the
United States is he the best man you
don't understand politics you don't
understand this country this is art
hochstätter former president of the
United States will he back the best man
power is not a toy that we give the good
children it's a weapon and the strong
man takes it and he uses it to get here
some men will stop at nothing
the film itself is it's very
entertaining and it's all about sort of
the manipulations behind the scenes it's
it's definitely a a strained movie in
the sense that a bunch of sort of wild
coincidences happen at the same time and
and there's a lot of scandal going on
it's an exaggeration of reality but it's
a it's a fun movie to watch and the
acting is quite good Cliff Robertson
particularly gives a very good
performance in it okay other things that
I like so Believe It or Not DeRay
McKesson tweeted something out that I
liked yesterday it was not anything of
contents or significance but it was very
funny back in 1996 Patti LaBelle sang
for Christmas and Patti LaBelle and
Patti LaBelle was singing some song that
I don't know she didn't know the song
either is the biggest is the bigger
problem so here's a little bit the video
of Patti LaBelle singing and she
realizes that she actually does not know
any of the words that she's about to
sing
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so you watching the whole that goes
on for two minutes like this it's pretty
amazing so thank you patti labelle for
giving us all a spot of cheer in a dark
time okay time for a quick thing that I
hate and then we'll get to the mailbag
alrighty so thing that I hate today
there's this tweet that was going around
yesterday that's just nuts it's from a
family a feminist of course so I needed
I didn't even need to tell you that it
was kind of crazy uh her she calls
herself mrs. Claus and here's what you
tweeted listen guys let me clarify
something for you when women's spaces
say men are welcome that's not true
we're just scared to tell you no so just
to be clear no means no but yes also
means no so everything means no unless
yes means yes but it probably means no
because you're scared if you're
wondering why men may be slightly
confused about what the standards of
behavior ought to be it's folks like
mrs. Claus who are not making things any
easier here okay time for the mailbag so
let's start with Robert Robert says Ben
what is your view on mandatory drug
testing for welfare recipients the
answer is yes good stuff the reason that
you should have mandatory drug testing
for welfare recipients is because there
should be some strings attached if the
idea on welfare is to get you back to
work we don't want you drugging out in
your free time and then going and
getting my taxpayer dollars to sponsor
your drug habit Matthew says hey Ben
knowing that Trump has declared
Jerusalem to be Israel's capital and
promised to move the embassy do you
regret not voting from last year we
consider voting from for reelection i
personally feel out switch my vote to
him so as far as regretting my vote I
could only base my vote on the evidence
that was in evidence at the time so I've
said where I think that I was wrong
about Trump right I thought that I was
wrong about him on Gorsuch I think he's
governed much more conservative than the
evidence suggested that he was going to
to that point I didn't think he was
gonna do it he just stayed on Jerusalem
he did it and I've given him I think
more than full points on that as far as
what I consider voting from next time
sure I'd consider voting for him next
time you know I'll look at the options
that come up and we'll see where we are
in three years but yeah of course I'd
consider voting form next time I
considered voting from last time so you
know I think that you can only make your
decision based on the evidence that was
at hand at the time but he has exceeded
my expectations in a variety of ways and
summer
he is not and I've been clear on that as
well Joseph says hi then I believe from
a theological and historical perspective
Jerusalem is the eternal capital of
Israel but how do I argue against those
who contain that contend that after 70
AD the Jews were evicted through
military means and thus lost their claim
to the land could the Mexicans or Native
Americans make the same historical and
ancestral claims about the southwestern
United States
well the answer is no the reason being
because even after the expulsion of Jews
in 70 AD Jews had a continuous presence
in the land and there was never an
independent state of Palestine that
existed outside of Jewish rule it was
always part of a broader Empire it was
never an actual state or land that was
run by an independent conglomerate of
people that just never happened so the
the longest-lasting group of people it's
more like a native Reservation than it
would be like anything else in the sense
that Jews were always there and
maintained a presence there and again if
you look at the original Native American
treaties in the United States before the
Trail of Tears in the attempt to force
Indians off their land
Native Americans off their line I think
there's a good case that those people
should know how to stay on their land
Heather says hi Ben I'm a big fan I
greatly respect your values politically
and personally my question is
religiously based I'm a critical-care
registered nurse I've had some
emotionally taxing events at work
recently I've never considered myself a
religious person lately I've felt a
desire for spiritual guidance I do not
belong to a church nor does my family
you have any advice on how I should
begin well I think that you have to
decide whether what you're looking for
is a community experience you're just
looking for a comforting religious
thought or deep religious thought I
think that good beginning religious
thought is CS Lewis I like a lot of CS
Lewis's work you should go check out his
religious thought I've recommended many
of his books including the abolition of
man and and mere christianity I my show
of momiji oh I think there's a lot Mira
Christian and they particularly the
first third before he gets to the super
Christian part that I agree with and so
that is that is worth checking out as
far as the community that you're looking
for I would check out some churches see
where you feel welcome see where you
feel like you find people who are
thinking along the same lines if you
have questions does the pastor or a
preacher some or priest somebody who is
ins answering those questions in a fair
and honest fashion morgan's has been how
did you know you wanted to marry your
wife and how long did it take for you to
propose I knew I wanted to marry her for
a couple of reasons so I think that here
is the typical pathway for men deciding
they want to get married first there has
to be physical attraction okay this is
just the reality when men
our first attracted to a woman it's
because there's a physical attraction of
the woman so my wife happens to be
smoking hot so this definitely was the
was the initial draw but the in the
first date I mean I dated a lot of women
one time and decided in one day anymore
because they were not either
intellectually stimulating or have the
same values she not only there was more
than just a spark there's what I'm
saying it's easy to find I think a
certain level of chemistry particularly
sexual chemistry with people I don't
think that's the hardest thing in the
world to find what is hard to find as
somebody who shares your values and my
wife and I on our first date for three
hours discussed free will and
determinism and how many kids we each
wanted to have I mean we're dating for
marriage and so you have to do I'm not
saying it saying sit there with a
checklist but you do have to have a
group of things in your head that you
want out of a spouse and I don't mean
like they're going to you know shine
your shoes or make dinner for you I mean
things like what kind of life do they
want to build and what kind of values do
they hold dear because that's the stuff
you're gonna be able to build a future
on Jonathan height has a chapter in the
happiness hypothesis about love and one
of the things he points out is that when
you first meet your potential mate then
the level of passion and passionate love
is an equals a passionate love and
companionate love compassionate love is
like here on the scale and companionate
love meaning how well you know the
person how much you love them for who
they are as a companion is down here and
this falls off from in about six months
passionate love falls off within six
months or a year a couple of years the
most it doesn't mean that doesn't exist
anymore but it just is different okay I
can tell you as somebody's in married
for ten years the feeling that you have
for your spouse particularly kind of the
kind of fiery need that you have for
your spouse at the very beginning is not
the same is not the same burning need
that you have for your spouse throughout
your life and the companion to love
tends to rise so passionate love
declines companionate love Rises that's
the way it should happen because
companion at love is more important when
you're building a life and building a
family who you want to have sex with is
a pretty arbitrary decision to a certain
extent
okay so Tanner says hi Ben I have a
quick question my older brother got a
girl pregnant he has only been dating
for maybe a month and a half does not
know what to do he wants to settle down
and get married with the girl take
responsibility for the kid she's
unwilling to get married and take
responsibility for the kid she wants to
put the kid up for adoption with my
brother which my brother does not want
to do I want to give him some helpful
advice what should he do well
here's my feeling if he if she's not
gonna take care of the kid and he is not
going to get married and adopt the kid
and have a spouse adopt the kid or if
your parents are not available to adopt
the children children need a mother and
a father a single father is not a good
solution a single mother is not a good
solution if those are the only two
solutions on the table put the kid up
for adoption
put them in a loving two-parent family
it would be a benefit to the child you
know the best outcome is biological
mother and father bringing up child on
average not for every family but on
average but it is more important that
the child grew up in a two-parent family
a solid two-parent family than that your
brother be with his own child there
being an active ferment of
self-sacrifice by a brother actually I
think to to put the child in the best of
living scenario unless your parents are
willing to adopt the kids the kid Joseph
says do you think Trump's become more
conservative since his first day in
office why are why not it's hard for me
to say whether Trump himself has become
more conservative I will say that his
policy has become more conservative his
policy in the last week and a half last
two weeks has been as conservative as
anything I've ever seen more
conservative than then I would say the
Reagan administration the last couple of
weeks but as far as him personally I
never get into the business of reading
what's going on in Donald Trump's head
because I think that that's a risky
business Jenna says heaven after years
of morning's learned the violin I
finally coughed up the money about my
first violin I've been taking lessons
for a few months now but I'm curious as
to what advice would be when learning to
play what is the most important thing to
remember when playing well I mean it
differs based on your skill level so
when you become as good as I am when
you've been playing for 15 years and you
better be good at that point or quit
when it when you've played I've been
playing since I was five years old so
what you're thinking about then is
making sure that there's musicality to
what you're playing you're actually
thinking about what you want things to
sound like when you're at beginning
stages it is really practice practice
practice make sure that all the muscle
memory is in place metronome is your
friend people tend to lose tempo
intonation is your friend if you have
somebody who can play the piano with you
that would definitely help because
otherwise you ends up with a sort of
bizarre relative pitch Tyler says what
individual in American history has
caused the most damage to the country
this is a good question there there
there there are many individuals who
caused tremendous damage to the country
I would say there's a very solid case
for well I mean
slave holders I would put Woodrow Wilson
up there I would put FDR up there I
would put LBJ up there there number of
demagogues who I think have driven
public opinion the wrong direction it's
hard to name one person but though I
would say that the leggo the legacy of
slavery continues to continues to
cruelly divide our politics even though
we all agree that slavery is bad now
Danny says I'm a cradle Catholic I take
my faith extremely seriously however in
the past few years I've felt extremely
drawn to Judaism which is where my own
Christian faith has roots the
subtraction is growing ever stronger
even through my own research and also
because of your inspiration I wonder
what your opinion was on Christians
celebrating Hanukkah and Pesach so the
halacha pinion is the christians the
kind of the Jewish law pinion is the
Christians shouldn't celebrate these
things I will you know add a bit of
heresy here I think that is fine for
Christians to celebrate these things I
think anything that connects you to the
god of the judeo-christian by a religion
is a good thing and Jesus celebrated
Passover so I don't really see the the
problem with this per se so the the in
fact my family has invited non-jews over
to Passover for years and for Hanukkah
parties so if you want to go for it go
for it whatever whatever makes you feel
closer to God Christoph says then I
believe your understanding of abortion
be somewhat flawed or at least there's
one part of your position you've not
been clear about this pertains when you
define life to begin to introduce what I
mean let me pose a very practical
question and one very applicable to go
200 couples that want to have children
for having difficulty doing so do you
support in vitro fertilization this
procedure always results in the
destruction of several embryos our
couples that pursue this method of
fertility killing humans in the process
so they are ending a human potential
incipient human life IVF I have always
said that if you have the money to use
every fertilized egg that's how IVF
should be performed and in fact I've
said this and there's a member of my
synagogue who his wife had gotten in
vitro and she had frozen the leftover
egg and they were gonna throw it away
and his wife said I don't think that
that's moral they implanted the egg and
they had a baby and this baby is now
their child I think that every every
fertilized egg ought to be treated with
the respect due to at the very least
potential human life and so if you're
going to treat in vitro in the most
moral possible way you
creates fertilized eggs just for
destruction instead you implant the
number of fertilized eggs that you're
willing to bear to fruition Michaels has
been what is your thought on the amount
of money we spend on the military we
spend it's less about amount than what
we spend the military money on and in
some cases we're spending it on
frivolous nonsense weapon systems we
don't need and all that but I don't
really have a problem with us spending
an enormous amount of money on the
military I think it's one of the only
decent functions of the government
let's see Nicholas says howdy Ben what
are your thoughts on the Rockefeller
Carnegie and Vanderbilt monopolies also
deal well we're going back to like 1880
here this is great what do you think the
government do you think the government
is right to break up the Standard Oil
Trust and should the government have
broken up other monopolies so I think
that the government was not right to
break up the trust I think a lot of
trust busting was based on a fallacious
assumption about how monopolies actually
operated a lot of those monopolies were
not actual monopolies and I think that a
lot of the trust-busting was basic class
warfare that was taking place at the
time to speak to specific trusts I would
actually do a little more research on
that so I will do that let's see okay
final one Philip says as a small limited
government proponent what suggestions
would you have to rationalize my desire
to fund NASA two historic highs and
literally shoot for the stars on outer
space science exploration I get the low
Earth orbit launches and deliveries to
the ISS are best suited to private
entities but there seems to be very
little motivation or reward for private
entity like SpaceX to explore for the
sake of exploration well I think you'd
have to talk about - Elon Musk about
that because I believe that Elon Musk
has actually talked about doing
deep-space exploration I if it's
privately fund about I think I'd be
great the only purpose for actual
government funding of deep space
exploration would be for defense
purposes or for the possibility of
creating you know new cures to disease
or something you know creating new
inventions but as a general rule I think
that NASA funding non-connected -
defense is a mistake and should be best
left in private hands I do think private
funding will fill in the gaps there I
mean as SpaceX is showing okay so we'll
be back here on Monday have a wonderful
weekend I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is austin stevens
edited by alex zingaro audio is mixed by
Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by Jess
well para the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for publishing 2017